hi I'm Erik Bosse in Star Wars Episode
nine the rise of Skywalker yeah that's
the title not the Emperor's New Groove
but we only in a trailer at Star Wars
Celebration with shocking connections to
the original trilogy and interesting
subtle choices by director JJ Abrams
that appear to be literally fixing and
metaphorically fixing elements that you
could say were broken
honestly totally coincidental shirt here
I woke up like this actually wear this
every night it smells terrible but I'm
gonna break down this new footage frame
by freaking frame for everything that
you might've missed and how episode 9
might conclude the trilogy of trilogies
spoiler warning in case I accidentally
predict anything to accurately and that
ruins your life we go let's get started
[Music]
please passed on only now okay this
trailer opens on black with only the
sounds of Rey's frantic breathing her
level of concentration reminds me a lot
of her meditation during our training on
octo in the last Jedi and her forced
vision in the force awakens suggesting
to me that this surreal imagery could be
a similar vision that she's experiencing
she stands alone on this desert terrain
this is shot in the deserts of Jordan in
real life
let's not clear if this planet is jakku
or Tatooine maybe a new desert planet on
her hip is Luke's lightsaber which
remember was severed in the last Jedi
but notice how it appears to be mended
he's got this black connective band in
the middle Daisy Ridley hinted on the
panel that Luke's lightsaber lives later
I'll explain how she might do that we
hear the voice of Luke Skywalker here we
passed on all we know Luke could be
speaking as a force ghost and it's
interesting that he says we meaning that
he could be joined by other ghosts of
fallen Jedi like Yoda Anakin Skywalker
Leia
maybe obi-wan Kenobi hello there qui-gon
jinn mace Windu may be that young gleam
anakin killed in the Jedi Temple let's
bring the whole game back but even more
stuff in the next clip the thousand
generations live in you now
[Applause]
but this is your find okay here we see
that Ray is standing off against a
charging Starfighter kinda looks like
kylo ren's the silencer though the
cockpit is different
we'll see it more clearly in the next
clip but notice the framing Ray's side
here with a drawn lightsaber and a
blaster and its holster this is a
western gunslinger framing that past
Star Wars films have used on Han Solo it
was used in the scene han met Jabba in
the original deleted scene in the first
movie and at George Lucas's updated
rerelease and last year Solo Star Wars
story paid homage to the gunslinger
framing as well so this frame dude sets
up Rey as if she were in a duel like she
was a matador or even in a medieval
joust like a soldier with a sword facing
an oncoming cavalry charge and then the
title card reads every generation has a
legend now they may be familiar to you
it was the same phrase in the title card
for the teaser of episode 1 Phantom
Menace remember the one back in 1988
that people bought tickets for the movie
meet Joe Black to just see the trailer
then they left after the episode 1
trailer in the previews sorry Brad Pitt
98 you were no Jake Lloyd or Jar Jar I
like that Jar Jar Abrams here use this
phrase again for episode 9 the
conclusion of the Skywalker saga to book
in this or as George Lucas would say
it's like poetry it lags on to the next
clip
whoa so notice the camera movement here
as the fighter wails closer and closer
the camera begins to track left gain
speed kind of like an Olympic relay
runner and a starting jog before the
baton handoff and that's sort of what
ray is doing here right rather than
facing the enemy head-on she turns and
runs in the same direction kind of
giving herself a head start before her
jump now we see someone's hands on the
controls of this cockpit this could be
kylo but again I'm just not sure because
this isn't really his tie silencer the
silencers cockpit had more of a
rectangle shape it didn't have this red
paint job so this could be a new tie
interceptor maybe a new ship of kylo or
if someone else entirely since I'm
assuming this is a vision of race it
could just be something she's imagining
and it's rey North by Northwest so a
from this ship she does this acrobatic
backflip creating the visual of a
literal sky Walker the rise of one some
might say and as this sequence wraps up
we move on to the rest of the trailer
[Music]
okay so one big mystery with the rise of
Skywalker is how this story will handle
the tragic death of Carrie Fisher
considering the last Jedi didn't really
end lay a story and episode 9 was
intended to be her story the way episode
7 was Haun's story and the way episode 8
was really Luke's story and in this clip
we start to get a hint of Laius presence
with this music this is a new
arrangement of John Williams classic
Leia theme we see of starfighters
swooping into a new planet a mountainous
rocky surface with a triple tiered
plateau containing some kind of city we
don't really know anything about the
setting yet but notice how each plateau
features a pointed structure on one end
of it this reminds me of the plateau on
Jetta and rogue one that was the ancient
Jedi holy city which had a great Jedi
Temple Jedi temples known for their
pointed pyramid like architecture like
jet huh pretty much all the remnants of
the Jedi tradition were wiped out
throughout the Galactic Civil War and
about 66
maybe this mountain range hides a
surviving trace of it
geez Abrams has said that this story
will not pick up immediately after the
last Jedi and sometime will have gone by
so presumably the meager surviving force
of the resistance will have regrouped in
new locations with new star fighters
next there's kylo Ren using his
lightsabers cross guard and his vicious
takedown in the midst of some kind of
battle between first order stormtroopers
and what looks like resistance fighters
based on their helmets now someone said
that the guy that he body slams could be
one of the Knights of random who are
speculated to come back in this movie
considering they were JJ Abrams concept
and they're pretty much ignored in the
last Jedi and while I do hope that kylo
does reunite with the Knights of Ren
either to rejoin horses or in conflict I
don't think this guy's the Knights of
Ren I just don't think that this teaser
would spoil such a big reunion so
blatantly but next we see kylo shattered
helmet being fused back together so kind
of like Rey having fixed Luke's severed
lightsaber this is another example of
things broken in the last Jedi being
repaired and rather than interpreting
this cynically as like Abrams fixing the
things of the last Jedi broke about Star
Wars mythology I see it as more of an
evolution of the characters arcs the
healing of wounds and embracing scar
tissue as one's new identity
like maybe it's just me but the glowing
fissures on this helmet remind me a lot
of the hardened lava surface
of Darth Vader's home of Mustafar kylos
helmet was always intended to invoke his
grandfather and now this new scarred
version even more connects to Vader's
villainy also notice the hand that's
repairing it
that's that kylos hand it's covered in
hair almost like a chimpanzee
now the last Jedi made it very very
clear that there is not one hair
anywhere on Adam drivers upper body so
this must be some other being repairing
tylose helmet for him last year there
were some rumors that leaked that kylo
would experience some dream or vision of
Vader's origin moment in Revenge of the
Sith and maybe this scene will be part
of a parallel rebirth moment for kylo
moving on
[Music]
[Music]
okay here there's a quick shot of Finn
and Poe Dameron lovers of many a fan
fiction John boyega said that Finn
finally gets his own unique costume and
visual identity for this film as opposed
to you know like a first order deserter
who wears stolen resistance uniforms
borrowed poe jackets and a dripping back
to suit next a shot of bb-8 in this
amazing new droid for this film named do
he wheeled onstage for the celebration
panel and I just loved this little road
cone unicycle the concept art suggested
that its design was based on a duck and
it actually communicates with a
bird-like piano simply whistle in the
force awakens bb-8 sounds were based on
vocal work and noises made by actors
Bill Hader and Ben Schwartz so I'm
wondering if they'll do the same thing
with do but with different actors but
notice how it's designed continues the
tradition of r2d2 bb-8 as a simple dual
chromatic dirty and scratched up wobbly
antenna little rascal bb-8 and do appear
to be in some kind of droid workshop
maybe a factory you can actually see the
torso part of a protocol droid and other
spare parts behind them and I like how a
crane their heads may be there checking
out some thicker droid kind of like cuba
tucker and friday next there's a shot of
the Millennium Falcon cockpit containing
Chewbacca and Lando Calrissian with my
man the great Billy Dee Williams
reprising his role cackling just like he
did with me and Naaman the Battle of
Endor and noticed that Lando was wearing
the same yellow shirt that Donald Glover
wore is the character in solo a Star
Wars story next there's this interesting
speeder chase through a moisture farm
that's kind of look like moisture
vaporators there and this appears to be
the same planet that Ray was on you can
actually see the same Jordanian mountain
range in the background there's a land
speeder fleeing some first order
stormtroopers two of them on jetpacks
there's a closer shot of this land
speeder is Poe thin and Threepio guys
they look like freaking pirates Threepio
is clinging for dear life on what looks
like a mast and rigging of a boat all
this action just reminds me a lot of the
swashbuckling and opening of Return of
the Jedi there's also a quick shot of
what looks like an a wing with an engine
blown out crashing into a big Star
Destroyer but before we can really focus
on what's going on here there's a
close-up of this metal now this is the
metal that Leia awarded to Luke and Han
at the end of the first movie remember
the one that wasn't given to Chewie for
whatever reason
and speaking of chewy snobs they get
this real tearful moment Leia hugging a
crying ray no how did they do this I'm
wondering if they could have recreated
this using footage from the force
awakens remember the scene when Leia
hugged ray to console each other after
Hans death and yes looking back it was a
little weird for Leia to hug ray here a
girl she would have just met and not
Chewie her old friend even JJ Abrams
admitted this is weird
during this embrace you can see that
Leia still wears her jewelry or a weave
bracelet Herodium earrings and signet
ring in the Star Wars universe rings
with signet emblems mean organization
membership or rank within the Rebel
Alliance let's move on
[Music]
okay this section shows us pretty much
the full team shuuyu with his bow caster
bb-8 do
Threepio rey poe and thin nice blue
pants JJ Abrams said on the panel that
this film would feature the full group
on an adventure together
suggesting that they will not be split
up on three different arcs as they were
in the last Jedi so just like the broken
props being fused back together so are
the characters in their relationships
they're standing on a cliff looking out
of this thing now this is actually a
massive chunk of a Death Star it looks
curved so I'm guessing it's a piece of
the giant focus lens firing disc it's
looming and haunting evoke being the
original Star Wars concept art by Ralph
McQuarrie it's almost as if the
gargantuan size of these ruins are
affecting the tide of this body of water
funneling the rapids and air flow
reflecting how even the rotting corpse
of the Empire still creates danger
around the galaxy this debris could be
from the first Death Star suggesting
this would be on or around Yavin 4 which
is Poe's home planet but it doesn't
really look like a forest environment
there or it also could be the second
Death Star putting this honor around
Endor but this doesn't look like the
forest moon of Endor where the Ewoks
were either so why are these characters
here well some of the concept art for
the force awakens depicted ray who was
back then still known as kira exploring
the submerged wreckage of the Death Star
and they later adapted it so that she
would be scavenging the wreckage of a
Star Destroyer on jakku but maybe the
rise of skywalker will return that
concept with ray perhaps scavenging for
Kyber crystals to repair Luke's
lightsaber that could be how she does it
we actually learned that kylo retrieved
Vader's helmet from the funeral pyre on
Endor maybe ray could be doing something
similar or if this is the Death Star -
maybe there's an even darker presence on
here which we here in this next clip
yikes so we hear the iconic cackle of
Emperor Palpatine also known as that
Senate and if there's any confusion over
whether this was just a sound effect
used for the trailer
Ian McDiarmid himself actually made a
post trailer cameo on the celebration
stage so yeah Palpatine will actually be
in this movie but how is this possible
in the Star Wars mythology Sith are
unable to fully appear as force ghosts
the way Jedi can because the person must
have fully rejected the dark side in
order to do that but the Sith had been
known to stay as a spirit after their
deaths like attaching to an item Horcrux
tile the way darth nihilus controlled
his robes or how momen remained in the
mask in the recent run of the Darth
Vader comics remember in Revenge of the
Sith Palpatine did share the legend of
Darth Plagueis the wise the Sith who
discovered a way to bring people back
from death teaching this power only to
his apprentice who murdered him in his
sleep there was some speculation that
that apprentice could have been Sidious
others have disagreed with this timeline
some say Palpatine just made up the
story in order to manipulate Anakin but
Palpatine's return could totally
recontextualize what we know about
supreme leader Snoke
whose death seemed a bit abrupt in the
last Jedi perhaps Snoke was serving or
being controlled by the spirit of
Palpatine that could explain why Snoke
and by extension kylo never really knew
about Vader's humanity as Anakin
Skywalker that would have been a secret
that would have died with the greater
evil Palpatine and never shared with
Snoke the laughs leads to the reveal of
the title the rise of Skywalker now
there are a lot of ways we can interpret
this title first there is some lovely
George Lucas style poetry at play here
the ends of each of the three trilogies
have parallel titles the Revenge of the
Sith The Return of the Jedi and the rise
of Skywalker revenge return rise Sith
jedi skywalker the skywalker in question
could refer to kylo ren the surviving
heir to skywalker bloodline as the son
of leia perhaps suggesting his rise into
the light a few months back there was a
rumor about a threat from the beyond in
this story and that threat could be
Palpatine who drives kylo back into the
good side or maybe the rise could refer
to some ascendancy by the spirits of
Luke and Leia into a higher plane of
existence some are saying the rise
Skywalker could also suggest that we
finally learned the origin of Anakin
Skywalker who was born under mysterious
circumstances
no father one theory that I liked is
that considering episode 9 is meant to
be the final goodbye of the Skywalker
saga maybe the term Skywalker no longer
refers to a specific name of a person
the last Jedi was meant to be the
extinction of the Jedi Order and the
dualistic conflict with the Sith if Luke
was the last Jedi
perhaps Skywalker could be the term for
force practitioners in the next
generation similar to how followers of
Jesus Christ took on the name Christian
the rise of Skywalker could refer to Rey
the first lower s Skywalker
of this new movement now sure we have
been told in the past that Skywalker is
just a common surname in the Star Wars
universe
I can dismiss and that's why no one
assumed Anakin Skywalker and Luke
Skywalker were related but also the way
that Smith in our universe once had a
practical meaning the name of one's
trade like a blacksmith or a silversmith
perhaps to this final chapter will
redefine Skywalker as a specific
function in society those who carry the
torch of Luke Skywalker's more nuanced
balanced view of the force now the worst
some more details revealed that
celebration like a new character played
by Naomi a key jana and a new alien
resistance Ally named Claude but my
question to you is do you want the rise
of Skywalker to retcons some of the
controversial plot twists in the last
Jedi or do you want it to build on them
comment down below with your thoughts
follow me on instagram and twitter at EI
vas and subscribed into rock stars for
everything Star Wars related to
breakdowns of everything you love
also if you plan to go to VidCon this
June please tweet at VidCon and let them
know that you'd love to see us host a
panel a live show a meet-and-greet who
just loved to hang out with you guys and
nerd out about Star Wars thanks for
watching bye